Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to talk about and start on the
discussion of the first set of
investment philosophies which are all
built on looking at past prices and
taking advantage of them. Along the way,
we'll run into charting and technical
analysis. And we look at what drives
many of these, which is momentum, and
the basis for that momentum. To get this
process started, I'd like to start with
what finance or traditional finance
would offer as the counter to looking at
past prices, which is called the random
walk hypothesis. Saying what the heck is
the random walk hypothesis? The random
walk hypothesis argues that in the next
instant for any stock, prices are just
as likely to go up as down. That there
are no patterns in stock prices. That
might sound absurd to you, but let's
look at the basis for the random walk
and then we can look at why why it might
not hold in the real world. It starts
with a presumption that all information
about the firm is publicly available and
traded on. Investors get that
information. They form expectations and
if they're rational, these expectations
are unbiased. You know what I mean by
unbiased, right? They're not set too
high, they're not set too low. Prices
react accordingly. So the price reflects
those unbiased expectations
and then investors are not able to make
money on those expectations. A new piece
of information comes in. Remember the
existing price reflects what's known
about the company. The next piece of
information is then just as likely to be
good or bad news. So the 50/50%
chance of good news, a 50% chance of bad
news. The price change then reflects
that incremental information. And
because the information is half good,
half bad, the price change is just as
likely to be up as it is down. That is
the random walk that in any given
moment, the next piece, the next moment,
stock prices or a stock is just as
likely to go up or down. Which means no
matter what the historical price bath
is, there's nothing you learn by looking
at it. That's a random walk hypothesis.
And the reasons it might not hold. First
is that investors are not always
rational about setting expectations. So
even if you start with the assumption
that information is public and everybody
has it, investors looking at the
information and not always rational.
Sometimes they're biased upwards,
sometimes they're biased downward. The
minute you introduce bias into
expectations, the random walk starts to
break down. Because if you're biased in
expectations, you're over optimistic,
for instance, then the next piece of
information is more likely to contain
bad news than good news because you've
set your expectations too high. If
you're over pessimistic, the reverse
happens. The next piece of information
is more likely to be good news than bad
news. And already you can see one reason
why random works might break down.
Second, price changes themselves might
lead to might be information. In other
words, investors in addition looking at
information on earnings and cash flows
and whatever else getting up getting
about the company might be looking at
what other investors are doing. So
they're buying that might be viewed as
good news which in effect can lead the
next price change to be affected by the
last one. So not everything moves in a
random work and that's at the basis for
much of charting and technical analysis.
People have used price charts and price
patterns for as long as we've had
financial markets. And one of the ways
to start thinking about price charts and
price patterns is to go back to your
statistics class. In a random walk,
price changes are uncorrelated. What
does that mean? What happens in the next
period has nothing to do with what
happened in previous periods. If you're
a momentum investor, you believe that
price changes are positively correlated.
What What does that mean? If price
changes have been, you know, positive
for the last few periods, the next price
change is more likely to be positive
than negative. If you're a reversal
investor, you think price changes are
more likely to be negatively correlated.
In other words, if prices went up in the
last week, they're more likely to go
down. So correlation becomes the
statistical device we can use to
separate momentum from reversal and
bringing in random walk in the middle
where the correlation is zero. If you
look at the studies that have looked at
price change correlation across time you
can classify them into four groups.
In recent years as we've had more data
on intraday price changes studies have
focused on minutes and hours. Does
knowing what happened in the last
minute, the last second help you predict
the price change in the next minute, the
next second? The short term could be
days and weeks. Is there knowing what
happened yesterday help you predict what
will happen to stock prices today? Is
knowing what happened last week help you
predict price changes next week? Those
are the short term. The medium term is
months. Is knowing what happened to a
stock in the last 6 months, the last
year help you predict what will happen
in the next 6 months or the next year?
And the long term, where is knowing
what'll what happened to a stock in the
last 5 years help you in making a
prediction what will happen in the next
5 years? With all of these studies,
we're going to use correlation as a
common language. When you start with the
really short-term minutes or hours,
there are two dwelling effects pushing
in opposite directions. There's a market
liquidity effect. If markets are not
liquid, it induces serial correlation
that's positive. And here's why. If
markets are not liquid and good news
comes out, as stock price goes up, it
takes a while for that information to
play through. So you might have over the
next minutes or even the next hours
increasing prices. If bad news or
reverse happens. So liquidity creates
positive serial correlation in returns.
At the same time, you got the bid ass
spread. If you remember the bid ass
spread the the bid and the ask prices at
any point in time capture the difference
in price between trying to buy the stock
and sell the stock to the extent that
trades know zigzag between buys and
sells you can have a bounce between the
bid price and the ask price. So you
start ask bid ask bid that's going to
create negative correlation because
you're moving you're moving back and
forth between the bid ask spread. In
fact, there's a paper that actually
estimates how much the bid ass spread is
by computing the negative correlation in
very short-term stock prices. So, two
effects pushing in opposite directions.
A liquidity effect creating positive
serial correlation, a bit spread
creating negative serial correlation.
Before you get too excited though, these
correlations are really, really tiny and
they don't last very long. So to be able
to take advantage of them, you got to be
able to trade almost instantaneously
and on scale. You got to do it in no not
in a thousand dollars, but tens of
thousands, tens of millions of dollars.
There's a and there's a there's a
segment of trading called high frequency
trading. We'll talk about this later in
in a in a different in a different
context where computers were put to play
trying to take advantage of the serial
correlation by big institutional
investors and for a while it did make
money for them. But the problem is it
gets imitated quickly. Highfrequency
trading made money for a few months
perhaps even a few years before other
people brought in their own computers
and once you start to do that the excess
returns go away. So in the really short
term there is evidence of correlation
but it's small and unless you can do it
on speed and scale very difficult to
take advantage of and even with speed
and scale not a source of excess returns
for the long term.
What about in days and perhaps even
weeks? There is some serial correlation
in daily returns but it's really small
and not easily exploited. In fact the
early studies found some evidence of
correlation. Some found positive serial
correlation, some found negative, but
they're all small enough that you can
say statistically there's correlation,
but I can't make money on it. In fact,
with more recent studies come back with
uh with findings that push in both
directions. Again, you're going to find
this a common theme when you look at
pricebased correlations. Studies push in
both directions. With high volume
stocks, there's some evidence of
reversal, negative serial correlation
over short periods. With low volume
stocks, there's more evidence of
positive serial correlation. And none of
these studies find serial correlations
that are large enough for you to be able
to exploit to make money. So in the
really short term, you've got this mix
of uh of negative and positive. The
short term, you again have this mix and
in both cases very difficult to take
advantage of to make excess returns.
You're saying what if happens if I go
from days to months
here there is evidence of correlation
that's more significant larger more
positive serial correlation and it does
look at least on paper that you can take
advantage of this one of the more famous
studies of this was by Jagadish and
Titman where they found price momentum
in returns over 6 months if you took the
stocks that have gone down the most have
gone up the most over the last 6 months
they're more likely to continue to go up
over the next six months. months gone
down the most. They're more likely to go
down. So this this continuation of
what's happened in the past and they dis
they found at least based on again on
paper that if you invested on this
momentum effect, you'd have made 16.5%
higher returns than somebody who
invested in the stocks in the bottom
desile. So the top decel of momentum
versus the bottom decile. That's large
enough to make a difference and you can
see it show up here. In fact, these are
the returns on 10 classes of stocks
based on momentum. We're looking at
momentum over the last year. And this is
um from Ken French's very useful
database at Dartmouth updated through
2024. So what I've done in this is
looked at the returns you could have
made on average for each of the momentum
class from lowest momentum to highest
moment. Highest momentum are the stocks
which did the best last year. the lowest
momentum of the stocks that did the
worst and you can see there is some
evidence of a difference in returns
almost a 10% difference in the lowest
and the highest and the excess returns
reflected. So at least on paper it looks
like there's enough momentum in short in
medium-term returns 6 months a year for
you to be able to take advantage of to
make money. And if you look at the
momentum more closely and look across
stocks, here are the things that people
have discovered in different studies.
First is they find that momentum
accompanied by higher trading volume is
stronger and more sustained than
momentum with low trading volume.
Momentum at small companies is stronger
than momentum at large companies.
On upside versus downside momentum, it's
a split effect depending on the time
period you look at. If you look at the
entire time period, upside momentum
dominates, but there have been sub
periods where downside momentum has won
out. And finally, momentum tends to be
stronger and more sustained at high
growth companies than at mature
companies.
So, if there's a hopeful theme here for
traders, it is that at least over months
or even, you know, one-year period,
there is momentum. this and that
momentum can make you money enough money
to cover your transactions cost and
trading costs. Maybe that explains why
there are so many people who trade
rather than invest. What happens if you
go from 6 months or a year to 5 years or
10 years really long-term here you get a
flip that positive serial correlation
you saw with six month returns or
one-year returns becomes negative serial
correlation. So if you look at five-year
periods and you look at the stocks that
have done the best over the last 5
years, they're more likely to be the
worst performers over the next 5 years.
And the worst performing stocks the last
five years tend to become the best
performing stocks over the next 5 years.
Over the long term, it looks like
negative correlation is bad.
So here's the bottom line on
correlation. If you look at, you know,
at high momentum versus low momentum
stocks, it varies by year. Your winning
years, losing years, and that's
something to factor in. There's no
consistent winning strategy with
momentum because it looks like it goes
through phases where it wins a lot and
phases where it doesn't work at all.
Something to factor in. Overall though,
when you get extreme momentum,
you get what people call bubbles. I know
people are quick to label almost
everything a bubble, but if you have
momentum in one direction for really
long, you have essentially a really big
momentum drive. And there's a
correction, that correction is going to
be large as well. And that's what's that
that has often become the basis for
price bubbles. The dot bubble, the
social media bubble, now the AI bubble.
One of the problems I have with that
word is it already is quick to classify
this as irrational. And I'm going to
argue that it's very difficult to
actually differentiate
between what I call a mis a blooper
which is a mistake that markets make all
the time and a bubble. Rational markets
can make mistakes. So in hindsight you
might look at something and say that
looks like a bubble but might be
entirely rational. A bubble is a willful
error where you override information.
You choose to push prices up. So the
question is how do you draw the line?
And I think it's really difficult to do.
In hindsight, you might say that was an
obvious bubble. But let let me give you
a couple examples. The gold prices
between 1970 and 86. Gold prices soared
in the la latter half of the 1970s. Why
did they so? Because inflation was high.
Now, if you look at gold prices, by the
time you get to 1986, it looks like a
classic bubble, right? The stock, the
gold price went up, then it went back
down. You're saying, but was it? In
1979, there was a very real chance that
we might not bring inflation under
control. Remember, it took Paul Vulkar
and a three-year recession to bring
inflation under control. So what you
have in hindsight might look like a
bubble but it might actually just be a
markets making a judgment about the
future and that judgment turns out to be
wrong. Doesn't make it a bubble. In
contrast, if you look at the NASDAQ
between 1994 and 2001, there's much
better evidence here that this was a
bubble in hindsight, that there wasn't,
you know, a basis for the pushup you
saw. But as I said, drawing that line
between a blooper and a bubble is really
difficult to do. So with that long lead
and let's talk a little bit more about
bubbles because this is momentum at on
steroids, right? Every bubble has four
phases. There's the formation of the
bubble. You know what causes the bubble
to come together in second there's a
sustenance of the bubble. There are
things that are feed into keeping the
bubble and and making it bigger. There's
the bursting of the bubble and then
there's the aftermath of the bubble.
Every bubble shares these four faces,
but no two bubbles are exactly the same
or even close to being the same. Which
is one reason even if you've lived
through the dot bubble, it doesn't give
you any additional ammunition when you
hit the next bubble. If you think AI is
a bubble, it doesn't help you that you
were there for the com bubble. So, let's
talk a little bit about what is it that
creates and sustains a bubble.
Every bubble starts with a kernel of
truth. A reality that just gets
magnified perhaps more than it should
be. But there's a kernel of truth. Let's
go back to the dotcom bubble, right? The
kernel of truth there was the internet
was changing the way we live, we work,
we interact. That was true. People
overdid it. But there's a kernel of
truth. That kernel of truth leads to you
want there's a fear of missing out. You
invest in companies that are in that
space and then news about how much money
you're making gets out of other people
come in and imitate what you do and the
bubble gets bigger and bigger. Now you
can take whatever bubble you're come
you're familiar with and this process
plays through right kernel of truth
initial winners other people watching
the winners coming in and the crowd gets
bigger and the bubble gets bigger but
bubbles would never get as big as they
do without an ecosystem feeding them on.
And here's the ecosystem. When you have
a bubble there are people who make money
in the bubble. It could be academics
writing research papers. Maybe they're
not the biggest, you know, but but in
terms of the people who make money, it
be investment bankers, consultants,
brokers, portfolio managers,
and they now have a vested interest in
not only preserving the bubble, but
making it bigger. and they get in
intellectual support from those
academics and intellectuals who give
them a way of justifying the bubble to I
won't say the word suckers because it
sounds like I'm insulting people but
investors are not in the bubble yet to
try to get them in. So there is a
sustenance of the bubble and every
bubble has this ecosystem that feeds
into it and sustains it. Eventually
though every bubble burst what causes
it? I don't know because each bubble
seems to be triggered. It's not some
usually there isn't a single
precipitating event a day we all wake up
and say oh my god that was a bubble
seems to be a collection of small cuts
but the there are two things that I
think that cause a bubble to burst one
is a bubble needs new investors new
funding coming in constantly so like a
Ponzi scheme which is a scam a bubble
might not be a scam without new
investors coming in it runs out of
oxygen that's the first problem the
second is there's overreach
There's a point in every bubble where
you start to see overreach. People
coming in or companies coming in trying
to get list and say, "No way. That can't
be right." Those of you who live through
the com bubble, you saw those companies,
especially towards the end of the
bubble. You said, "Clearly, we're
reaching the end of our tether. These
are companies that are overreaching."
And when that first hint of doubt grows
in, people push it away. But there's a
triggering point where once people start
to panic, it becomes a full-blown rush
for the exits and that's what causes
bubbles to burst. But because the
precipitating factors are so difficult
to identify, it's difficult to forecast
when that'll be. You're saying but Alan
Greenspan forecasted the bursting of the
dotcom bubble. Alan Greenspan famously
who's the Federal Reserve chair
described uh the dotcom bubble as
irrational exuberance. You're saying
that is good. He saw what was coming. He
made that statement in 1996. You know
when the bubble burst 2001
eventually everybody looks like a market
expert if I give you five years to be
right. So it is you know no bubbles
burst. We don't know what causes them to
burst or what the precipitating factor
is.
Along the way though, I would argue that
much as people look back at bubbles and
say never again, that's a terrible
thing. Argue that bubbles are a feature
of markets, not a bug. Especially when
you have big markets that are still
forming. I call this the big market
delusion. And here's how it starts. It
starts with a big market. Could be
China. It could be AI. It could be.com.
And when you have a big market, it
attracts people who want to make money
in the market. Entrepreneurs who tend to
be overconfident people think they can
conquer the market. So you have an
overconfident entrepreneur who attracts
venture capitalists tend to be
overconfident people think they picked a
winner and they're going after the big
market. You're saying why do you keep
introducing overconfident into your
story? What does overconfident mean?
They overestimate their chances of
winning. They overestimate how much
revenues they can make. They overvalue
their company.
And there are hundred clusters just like
yours of overconfident entrepreneurs
surrounded by overconfident VCs thinking
they can beat that they can conquer this
market. If you add up the values of all
100 companies given the overconfidence
the sum of the values is going to be too
high. The market they're going after is
not large enough to sustain all of them.
But initially you don't know it's still
unformed. You don't have that evidence.
Eventually though, as the data comes in,
the correction kicks in. I've given you
three examples of of booms and bust.
You've got the dot boom and bust. You've
got the online ad market in 2015 where I
took every publicly traded company in
the online ad business, estimated what
they would need as revenues to justify
the market cap and added up all those
revenues you would need and said the
overall advertising market is not big
enough to sustain all of these
companies. and a correction ensued.
There was a cleaning up phase. Same
thing with cannabis stocks. Initially
when they came out, people were just
excited. This is going to be the next
great business. And it very quickly
cleaned up again. Now, while people
often look at these bubbles and say
never again, they want regulatory
protection against them. This is again a
feature of big markets. And much as we
don't like the damage that comes from
the bursting of the bubble, it changes
the way we live, right? That dot bubble,
even though it does, change the way we
live. You know, the online advertising
market might clean up, but ultimately
we're getting most of our ads online.
That cannabis market might have cleansed
itself, but more people are smoking
cannabis than ever before. So much as
the we look at these bubbles and bursts
as as bad things, they change the way we
live and it's human nature. We
overreach, we correct and we overreach
again. So much as you know we want to
classify bubbles as a bad thing as
irrational, it might be part and parcel
of how markets work. So here's the
bottom line. Are stock prices correlated
across time? That was an easy question,
of course. But the correlation actually
varies depending on the time period you
look at and depending whether you're
looking at daily, weekly, intraday, six
month, one year, five years, you got
positive correlation in some, negative
correlation other. You know what that
implies, right? Essentially at any given
point you look at markets, you're going
to see people trading on momentum and
you're going to see people trading on
reversal at exactly the same time.
strategies coexist that seem
contradictory, but they're trying to
take advantage of differences depending
on your time horizon. So, as you look at
all of these strategies, in general, at
least the evidence seems to indicate
that all of these strategies, whether
it's momentum or reversal, work better
if you have less liquid, higher growth,
smaller cap companies than they do on
larger cap, more liquid stocks. But the
allure of trading is this correlation.
And I think that the, you know, it's
we're far too quick to dismiss it
sometimes as value investors and people
that think that's irrational. There's
nothing irrational about trading based
on past prices. So, we'll build on this
theme in the next session by looking at
technical analysis and charting
indicators. But I hope you found this
session useful at least as an
introductory session. Thank you very
much for listening.